and the Oscar goes to
Italy's 26th nomination and it's ten
Academy Award
thank you so yeah I live here the Oscar
but I want to you I want to be rocketed
by the way we suffer your beauty
come here thank you thank you this is a
moment of joy and I want to kiss
everybody because you are the image of
the joy and he who kisses the joy as it
flies leaves in eternity sunrise then
said the poet and this is wonderful to
be here wonderful I feel like now really
to to dive in the ocean of a great a
loveable generosity this is too much
your generati season and how do you say
when they're a yeah there
the hailstorm it's a hailstorm of
overwork kindness over over a gratitude
for you when they really have the life
to take everybody did the movie because
we can without them I couldn't to fly
with the Smoove everybody did the
producer the screenwriter cher ami L the
fairy and geogebra skinny Cola Pahlavi
Vittorio shakey Gauri Harvey why Steve
Miramax people thank you very much for
what you did and don't share with the
lies to take my parents in Virg I are in
the little village in Italy they gave me
the biggest gift of poverty and I want
to take them before the rest of my life
really well thank you mama bubble
thank you and thank you for your love
because it's a brief I am here is
because people laugh at the movie so
it's always a question of love the light
to dedicate this prize to those because
the subject when a movie those who are
not here they gave their life in order
we can say life is beautiful and I would
like to also say a kiss to George you
can't really tell George or the little
boy and because we are talking the lava
Dante said the LaMarca mobile soul ll
cristela lava move the Sun and the other
star say lava is a divinity and
sometimes if you have a faith like all
the divinities he can appears that's why
I want to dedicate this prize to
Nicolette the brass thank you
you